okay guys okay it's your boy
psychobabble I ever playing block HUD
you know like block and dad you know
it's a gang reference anyway I'll
playing challenging were seven called
chairs vertical farming and get here we
got here you go intermedia let's do this
now this games skin can't [ __ ] hard
on a canal I am weary sweating sweating
like a pig a with too much mustard on
his lab you know mmm okay God get good
and ok wait what the [ __ ] is my
effective again beer and money but don't
have too much waste ok so you're gonna
do you're gonna do that classic the
classic two trees start [ __ ] we got like
no [ __ ] around okay I can guess which
takes biogas and money good good waste
okay okay
I am no stranger to [ __ ] bail gonna
okay that's all I'm gonna say no
stranger sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] it okay and I
like to do my little elevator Oh God God
can't get can
I cannot then if it costs money that's
all I'm gonna say let's say here we need
not wait so money that's always had [ __ ]
on it mommy Oh cut good [ __ ] here
labor and consumer okay oh [ __ ] it's his
face on the right way now okay any more
beer though the brewery okay I'll play a
little game I'll plant yeah I mean I
don't want to play it but i'll plan yeah
this guy you want to [ __ ] up right
that's all i gotta say you guys are in
for a treat to see a real disaster here
real [ __ ] to that let's say here okay
what it what is that I came to tell what
the [ __ ] that's making labor we lauder
shadow [ __ ] wheat [ __ ] okay I hate
making wheat um here sir here yeah i'm
just a wait little fun baby and just a
wee little farmer baby yeah baby baby
yeah baby okay great what is this
missing great so [ __ ] fertilizer is
what's missing okay what makes [ __ ]
fertilizer yeah okay
ah this is gonna be a really weird setup
okay I need some more consumers got get
good okay okay [ __ ] labor where
what's the beer situation where is it o0
I need more beer [ __ ] need more bear
and then were [ __ ] beer baby yeah
yeah sure can't see [ __ ] ok
yeah yeah oh my god nice and easy just
like Renault on it look any more [ __ ]
labor it's what I need get me some
[ __ ] house us baby yeah yeah yeah Oh
God God kept it it did get good
everything is going so good [ __ ] I don't
know more money um yeah baby yeah I know
you like it man some more lectures today
baby yeah yeah yeah I need some more
electricity baby anything yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure thing can make it
right there we go one more level down
can't see [ __ ] here sir Sir excuse me
sir oh very [ __ ] thats why hmm yeah you
got a second don't mind me and just get
in my part I'm no hero
can you remember what the [ __ ] is
jessica less than 100 organic waste [ __ ]
what's the thing that makes organic away
so no one [ __ ] out no no one [ __ ]
us of course not good good I'll just
make an anaerobic digester you know like
problem solved [ __ ] more lecture today
how much [ __ ] lecture these people
Nate ok where is it get get get get get
get get out good and I always love them
hi can i Ken okay that's your diet lets
us say a 500 beer that's a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] beer what is the beer thing ooh
that has grown away too slowly yeah
hello
oh [ __ ] that organic waste going to be
[ __ ] growing like crazy okay okay
[ __ ] area right
not God we're missing some labor [ __ ]
what's happening to that
ok
[ __ ] anymore [ __ ] choice
how do I
and I [ __ ] to make more trees
there we go
ok I think this is good pope [ __ ] man
you're parking for water how do I
ok and
[ __ ] out
okay well the mayor is growing what's
[ __ ] dying
the [ __ ] doesn't have a labor oh [ __ ]
come on come on soaked and soak it in
[ __ ] anymore lectricity
come on where can I put you all right
can I betcha
okay and does anyone know what the
[ __ ] happening now now not now I've
got gun
look at a little place very cute oh
thank you
and now we just facing out the way it
until this works
okay guys well this is that so basically
at this point everything is sustainable
the only thing we're watching out for is
organic waste which is only grown by
point zero one so I'm not worried about
that at all the beer is going to 5.8 and
the money is going up and X the money at
5.35 so we are good I was going to fast
forward and also make it meantime I
guess we'll just build try to beat this
thing up but but that's basically it low
enough time to single make it thanks for
watching us thank you